yay hi strange room oh that's a
terrifying work thank you for having me
I've been too terrified into a too
hungover jet-lagged well probably
hungover to whatever to see any of the
session so I'm really glad that I'm at
the beginning of the second day so after
this I can actually concentrate and see
stuff because I've been hearing about
this conference for years my name is
charity
I come from operations um I believe very
strongly that the only good dip is it
red disk I will write code when I have
to but I feel like code causes problems
and I don't like problems
I am the co-founder of a company called
honeycomb where we are focused on
observability for next generation and
emerging sort of infrastructure
methodologies I'll talk a little bit
about it but not too much because I'm an
engineer and I get really really wigged
out the I do you have anybody thinking
I'm trying to sell them anything so
we're just going to steer way over to
the other side of that that road the
relevant parts my background are Iran
engineering at parse for many years
mobile back into the service acquired by
Facebook rest in peace definitely not
bitter at all I've always hated
monitoring like lot like a lot a lot but
I've always felt like running at his
table stakes like any decent engineering
shop worth their salt or incident house
owns it you know I I do really strongly
believe in that whole you know you
should you should build the things that
are core differentiators for you and
your business and you should give every
other problem to every other person who
specializes in that other problem
because engineering cycles are the
scarcest resource in the world and you
don't have enough of them but for years
and years I thought that anything
related to understanding the software
you were building and shipping was a
core competency
like I would brick no argument a mess
alone change in the last three years
really
I wrote a review for
barrie schwortz of vivid cortex it's
still there in the internet it took me
about a week to evaluate his software
and write the article and at the end I
was like oh yep yeah he's doing this
better than I ever could and it's cool
and since then I've been very much in
the camp of you know yeah like
increasingly the visibility is is a
specialized skill set understanding what
that hell was even happening in your
software it's really hard and it's
getting harder so I loved it when Greg
said that monitoring was dead even
though he didn't he didn't mean it the
way I took it doesn't matter I was still
right um and he said you know my race
isn't they have not changed in decades
like fundamentally like we're still
there are people in this room still
running Nagios right thank you
Angra fruit salad of doom it's
terrifying we're still running that [ __ ]
so obviously I'm receptive to that
message I hate monitoring but I love
debugging like I love s trace more than
life itself I love all these sorts of
arcane bugs that you're never supposed
to have I love fire fighting but I will
deny it if I'm sober so like we're not a
monitoring company and I don't spend my
time thinking about monitoring and I
think that you know it kind of took me
by surprise that like the term
observability became contested but I'd
also kind of make sense we'll get to
that in a second we do kind of have to
spend some time on terms before we
really dive into it but like I feel like
that the meat like the core of this talk
is just it like complexity is exploding
in a nonlinear you know way but the
tools that we have for understanding our
systems are very much a product of the
lamp stack era assumptions like there
will always be a host to gather metrics
by every single person out there charges
by hosts crazy or the idea that all the
things in /proc are the most meaningful
things you can use to debug your problem
like and in so many ways like the the
the level of abstraction where we should
be even thinking about these problems
has moved from systems to cut
all right if your container you found
that out in a hurry all right our tools
are fundamentally designed to answer
known unknowns they do a good job of
that in Greg's talk he defined it as
like the actor observing blah blah blah
and this is outdated observability is a
term that's taken from control theory or
so Wikipedia tells me I don't actually
know but the way I've always heard it
and the way they think is relevant for
us is how much can you understand about
how your software works by looking at
its outputs by looking at the things
that you have like the little bits
you've planted whether it's slug lions
or whether it's events or whether it's
pictures like can you craft a story can
you you know how all of your dashboards
go like this at once
okay that's useful I guess only if you
couple it with enough intuition and like
like behind the scenes knowledge about
how do your system already works it's
not helpful if you're trying to learn
how your system already works sorry
rant my five minutes and go two dollars
back which is why we drink i I think
that observability is a superset
monitoring is opera it's it's
operability like when people say not for
opt you know people be very indignant
about this for years actually it is
monitoring's for ops ops is not a bad
word developers should do ops but my
hiring is fundamentally about checking
on your systems making sure that they're
still okay you know it's a defined you
know parameters of okayness this is an
operational task instrumentation is you
know how you develop a service which is
also not a bad word cuz operations
engineers develop software you know it's
like I find it so childish to go like
Ops is everything
no it's not well like monitoring so Ops
is biased towards outages right it's
biased towards failures because that's
what we care about usually when we're
operating software and it heavily
revolves around unknown unknowns once
something is known you can monitor for
it
when you see people talking about the
this massive explosion of metrics one
thing once they try to start trying to
monitor everything
well that's because you can't you can
monitor for your known failures
observability is about monitoring it's
about instrumentation it's about
answering questions about your system
when it's when it's a bad when it's an
outage when it's a failure and when it's
not right and when you're just like like
it encompasses the kinds of things that
business people need to know to do their
jobs well it encompasses debugging and
it just encompasses like how you answer
questions and if you're wondering how
you can tell if the system is observable
or not can you ask it the questions that
you need without jumping in and running
command-line tools which we all know and
love and we're all supposed to be
working our way out of using it's fine
it's totally fine and the reason that we
care about this is because complexity is
rising now I really sometimes people
start talking about complexity I just
did grinding my teeth just did what do
you mean you know and I hate it wouldn't
use this word they just threw it out
there to cover over the other words if
they aren't being very precise and I'm
thinking so they wanted to like oh well
it's complexity it bugs me but it's also
a real thing
now this laptop here is plenty [ __ ]
complex right what it's not really what
we're talking about we're talking about
complex systems and a distributed system
is technically any two nodes that are
talking across the network well it's not
really what we're talking about we talk
about the treated systems distributed
like the computer science of distribute
systems is at heart it's a way of
thinking about reasoning about
complexity right it's about moving that
complexity around to different parts of
the of your architecture where you can
deal with it better or perhaps worse
systems complexity is well all right I
drew you a graph that represents the
state-of-the-art computer science
so now you know it's true um how did
measure complexity assistant could
totally be a talk in and of itself I
went down a giant rabbit hole yesterday
while I was finishing my slides its
there's some really cool stuff out there
there's a like software complexity is
derived from like science modularity
coupling cohesion number of code paths
number of paths that the data can flow
through how much control flow exists is
called the cyclomatic complexity there's
halstead volume how much information is
in the source
so cool infrastructure complexity comes
from lays like of communicating between
them exposure to the external network
storage types oh my god remember back
when there was the database you had to
choose post grows or my sequel in this
those days like like yes you should you
should you choose boring software you
should choose predictable software
wouldn't you can but when you're a
startup or when you're building
something new so much of your
competitive advantage comes from rolling
the dice on the newer greener
technologies you know and I find it very
condescending when people just like well
you should just always use the boring
stuff it's like no you don't know where
problem solved
set price grew up with MongoDB best
thing that ever happened to them
that's another rabbit hole anyway anyway
so like lamps I'm I'm using terms lamp
stack and you know microservices even
though I know they're not really
accurate but just kind of to group
umbrella terms right like the last
decade of computing and like the decade
that we're embarking on now there's a
big difference in complexity between a
lamp stack and parse a couple years ago
you know we were a platform people could
upload whatever JavaScript they wanted
they could run whatever database queries
we wanted cloud code you know request
could loop back in multiple times and
that's why we put honeycomb like
honestly like if you rewind the clock
it's like we had built the system that
was fundamentally undie buggy bull by
around the times we got acquired so the
best engineers in the world could not
like one debuggable but it would take
hours days even weeks to track down
some of these bugs so it was not
debuggable from the perspective of we
have a team of 10 engineers who need to
give you team work done but it's complex
and interesting if that was like
Facebook's better or worse I started to
do worse better
let's goes better it's more like the
electrical power grid right I feel like
if you want to model system correctly in
your head for like the next generation
think about would this work for the
electrical grid right because there are
local problems you know nothing about
but you have to treat them anyway there
are systemic problems you will not know
about if you're only looking at local
problems it gets really fun let's go
through some example problems lamp stack
these will be very very familiar to all
of you someone complains photos are
loading slowly for some people why well
ok app capacity has exceeded every
latency your high database is saturated
you know like what all of these have in
common is you can pretty quickly tell
where they're coming from if it's a bug
in your code or whatever you want to
attach it to bugger and jump in and do a
deep dive there and like that's it and
this is very this is a very easy system
to monitor monitor these things done
characteristics of this system known
unknowns blah blah blah its friendly to
intuition you get a page and you need to
look at the dashboards half the time but
of course you have them many many many
dashboards [ __ ] hate - and the health
of the system more or less accurately
represents the experience of the
individual users who are using it cool
best practices monitor it a lot I don't
know like I said not too hard right a
runbook the things that exceed the
ability of like auto remediation so here
are there are some examples that we had
at parser Instagram
[Music]
any micro-services it happened running
on AC 2.4 XL and using provision type
storage in the US east 1b availability
zone has about a 1 in 20 chance of being
slow if it had to flush to disk and it
hotspots for certain users because of
the hashing like fan-out model just
makes certain you know segments hit that
more often this is a [ __ ] to track down
or like you know the Canadian users who
are using the French language pack on
this version of the iPad using this
version version of iOS like caching
doesn't work that should attract a town
or like you know this newest SDK gives
you a feature flag so that you can run
off database query sequentially
not even the bug like what am I supposed
to watch for you can't these are
problems or symptoms and I I had many
more slides of these believe me it was
like PTSD the trauma just keeps coming
but like any of these users right in and
they're like you know parses down and
they'd be so angry at me and I just be
like prices not down [ __ ] look
at my waffle or dashboard and they're
all green every single one of them be
green I get super angry but like I argue
with them and I'm just losing
credibility right it doesn't make it the
performance any better for them they
can't log in any more than they could
before I told him we were up and and
this was like their heart this was the
mean of the problem of the problem when
we got into Facebook and we put our
stuff on a scuba and they had like
pushed all these different tools on it's
none of the made a difference for us we
were still like reacting to symptoms as
though they were problems and and when
we got herself into scuba like it was
life-changing for me scuba is there were
white papers out there in fact I did
papers left talk summer on it it's just
a it is a janky-ass like piece of [ __ ]
software that like clearly was not
designed evolved to help them track
through databases handles wide events
and it's amazing ask any Facebook in
gelareh and
they miss that I changed my life I was a
better engineer with it that's we both
hunt you got honeycomb and honestly like
my grand plan with buying honey with
building honeycomb was so I'm leaving
Facebook PCs want to give me millions of
dollars I'm super gonna fail but I'll
take their money I'll build this thing
when we fail at open source it I'll
never have to live without it we just
keep top feeling so you know maybe maybe
someday but like you become a better
engineer when you're a window for
solving these problems goes from hours
and days to like seconds or minutes like
repeatedly and we'll always have in
common is fully have a lot of things in
common but there's a lot of unknown
unknown things there's a lot of things
that this will have one in a million
times
almost never well except if you're
Facebook it happens once every few
minutes right and then you and then you
get two categories of problems that are
like you know well this happens one
every thousand or 10,000 times when
intersected with this other thing that
only happens one out of every one dozen
times and like those like tracking down
those things require like four or five
rare things to happen non-trivial and
these are the problems that you I have
looked to look forward to you know like
the categories of problems that Google
has had and Facebook has had for however
long are the problems that more and more
and more people are having like sooner
and sooner and part of this is
self-inflicted like let me be very clear
like some of this is necessary
self-inflicted isn't some of it
containers and and and so it's not and
some of it is just thrashing around and
trying to figure out how to like deal
with just freight train of complexity
that's coming everyone's way which is
how I categorize microservices we've
been doing micro services since late
2007 Jesus Christ anyway sorry angry old
man the characteristics of these systems
unknown unknowns or most of the problems
like the system help this table stakes
like that's like you never even look at
it because it works right but you have
this long infinitely long
thin tail things that almost never
happen except that ones that they do and
usually you don't get good bug reports
you get symptoms that are described to
you by users and about 40% of the time
it's because they didn't turn on their
Wi-Fi which is extremely demoralizing to
the engineers that you're asking to go
track down this problem the hardest
problem is often just figuring out which
component it lives in so that you can
trace it or debug it or whatever because
they get everything's going like this at
once on your grass right and it's really
about the health of the system is no
longer as impertinent honestly if your
system was 75% down and all of your
users were having a good experience
would you care I wouldn't I would care
if it was 99.9% up and I was getting a
lot of complaints right so I don't
really feel like up or down or like is
it's all that meaningful when it comes
to system health what is important is
being able to find and identify every
single request and slice and dice by
every single characteristic that they
might share and the reason that I think
it's important to distinguish monitoring
from observability is there are some
very good time-tested best practices for
doing monitoring but do not apply to
observability and and I don't want you
to like to lose them right like like the
monitoring principle that is that says
that you should not have to go look at
your graphs every day to know if
something's wrong it should tell you
super agree with that do I want to get
paged about 20 [ __ ] thousand things
that I'm like trying to that I'm feeding
into my observability system no oh I
don't I don't want to get I don't want
to get paged about almost anything that
our users are going to complain about or
else all my engineers will quit and I
will too and the rest of talk we're just
gonna get into each of these and like
describe them a little bit more deeply
instrumentation I'm not even gonna
bother with this because I assume you're
already sold in this one I will just
point out that basically what we all
want is distributed estrus right we all
want distributed GDB we all want to be
able to hop around from node to node of
all these you know we've separated out
of mana list and the micro services and
this means that no component can
actually
debug the whole story for us and the
Holy Grail that we're all tracing is
something that can distributed tracing
is is cool for this like they take a
very depth-first approach how do you
come take is the brett-brett first you
know once you know what to trace all the
distribute trace is amazing honeycomb is
much more about what do I even trace
like seriously what then stopped metrics
this is super controversial but I don't
care there are a couple of reasons that
this is true cardinality is one raise
your hand if you've ever gotten high
cardinality datasets to work well with
metrics no and a lot of us have kind of
diluted ourselves into thinking oh this
is ok we don't really need it we really
care about it we're just fine we're
better off really I feel like there are
entire generations of engineers who have
have internalized limitations of metrics
as being limitations of data it is not
it is a problem with the metric itself
metrics can't be traced
they don't have contacts like events do
so like you all know what a metric looks
like oh this is a slide I didn't really
get finished well anyway so a metric is
a dot of data right it's an it's a
number and in order to get all these
numbers it's like well how do I find my
numbers well you that you append tags
and you could have some fixed number of
tags hundreds I don't know what data dog
does now the issue with this is it is
fixed the write amplification is huge
you don't want to append a lot of text
think of your bill ID infinitely
incrementing integer well if you want to
if you want the build idea to be a tag
which is possibly the most important and
meaningful tag that you would have and
you have to set up all this complicated
pruning whatever so a metric has all
these tags an event is just it's a log
line without the necessarily flushing to
disk right an event is a structured
sentence of data as many key value pairs
or as much much data structures as you
want and I understand why we got started
with metrics is because hardware was
obscenely expensive right like Google
back in the year 2000 like well I got
this really big website what am I good
how can I tell what it's doing well you
know
logs killing my system with logs let's
have metrics there's literally no less
data than we could possibly have in a
metric that sounds cool like hardware is
not that expensive anymore and also you
can example you can sample sampling is
amazing and there are some people who
have seem to have this weird allergy to
sampling which I understand if you're
building a billing system I do not
recommend that you sample your billing
system but for any of your operational
data it's not only a it's not only you
should do it's a must do it's just a
question to when a you don't want your
engineers acting like it's not sampled
because then they're going to make bad
decisions be you really want every
request to enters your system to
generate many events lots of lots like
every service if it goes through every
database that it goes through like [ __ ]
like a purse like I think we calculated
the average API requests generate about
50 events that Facebook it was hundreds
you know like you're not going to build
and observability your system that is
hundreds of times that of your actual
system therefore our sampling and you
can do it dynamically so that you're not
attaching equal weight to every single
every type of data right like every 200
status h-2b status code that came into
our system we kept 20% instagram kept
point one percent every 5 au x we kept
all of them right and we let the rate
limiter like slice off the top of the
mountain read queries we kept some
sample of them and delete we kept all of
them because people very rarely deleted
their apps and we wanted you know when
it happened sampling is awesome
cardinality literally all of the fields
that i most want to know information
about all of them tend to have very high
cardinality if you have 10 million users
like this is how Scooby changed our life
like on day one it was the ability to
break down first by that application ID
and then by every combination of
everything else boom like that's it like
suddenly we went from like just trawling
between like logs and metrics and
dashboards and all this [ __ ] and going
back and forth to just going oh I see
yeah okay you say parts
is down I see that every time you're
hitting the login end point it's taking
61 seconds because it's doing a 5x full
table scan and it looks like you
deployed that query there life-changing
it was amazing and and even the ones who
who like didn't turn on their at their
Wi-Fi you can just be like you're not
hitting our edge sir you know cuz you
can break down by by that like shopping
cart ID Rock queries means it's
cardinality man this will save you we we
did have to write our own storage engine
to do this though nothing else out there
could do it believe me after I've spent
my entire career telling people not to
write databases and I stand by the fact
that I have it it's a storage engine
hi cardinality is not nice to have it is
it is a must-have and especially for
platforms platforms are kind of the
bellwether and and I defined platform as
as something where you're letting users
define a great deal of the behavior
right it's not just the queries that
your software engineers over there wrote
its queries that god-knows-who over on
the other side of the planet wrote and
you can't throw things at them like ever
by definition it's a platform in the
future most of us our platform then part
of this is just because it's what the
market is demanding is that richer
feature set with more user defined
controls and with user defined controls
comes great chaos and these tiny these
tight like humans just yeah humans
inject chaos you know that I'm not even
gonna bother with that one and
structured data like structure your
[ __ ] data is 2017 is almost 2018 why
does anyone have any unstructured locks
string processing is not getting any
faster another another thing about this
is is that no never I think that's in a
later slide
let's get it event still stories like
like this so like metrics you never
going away and I don't I loved metrics I
do i I just I make big statements cuz
it's what I do
but like Facebook still has a very large
metrics system ods Amazon does it they
managed to combine them into something
that's even better I think
but anyway metrics are great but they
don't really tell stories and they don't
come with the rich context you know any
event that you and that you submit has
all of the the details about the request
and then it has all the context you can
pack in there about who it was for and
when and what would Steve the system at
the same time they're much more
explanatory they're much more powerful
this is how our brains work our brains
tell stories structure your data yes all
over the source tree
well efficiencies that's boring whatever
what about my dashboards well what about
your dashboards
every place that I've ever worked has
gotten dashboards to find your
dashboards with your dashboards
dashboard rot it's awful the fit the
reason I hate dashboards so much it sees
dude facetiously is every dashboard is
basically an artifact of a past failure
right you're doing it postmortem
and you're like I could instruct the
dashboards will find this problem
immediately the next time okay cool
so the next time something happens you
just start jumping to answers you're
just like answer is it this way oh is it
that one is it that one like every
single one of them perfect
representation of a particular failure
you're not actually doing computer
science you're not really even debugging
you're not asking questions or
falsifying hypotheses about how the
world works you're not going what about
this and then what about this point but
that's no you're just like aha I got it
oh no not that one ah I got it like I
hate that I hate that I hate that
feeling of your eyes just like darting
around like this well maybe it's this
maybe it's that oh I can't keep using
the same dashboard until unless I write
some like it's like eyeball exercises
but it's what it's not is debugging and
you get like this dashboard blindness
when you've been looking at him for a
while where if you did not remember to
graph a thing you could be jumping
around in dashboards with two hours
before you remember oh wait did we never
set graphs up for that or huh
maybe maybe I think stop collecting data
you know let's go look at it in the way
that you build up a richer mental model
of your incredibly complex system when
you're asking questions and iterating on
them dashboards are like they're like
they just short-circuit that entire
process I think that engineers I don't
think it makes for good engineering I've
seen engineers become better by doing
exploratory iterative interrogations of
their systems dashboards must die once I
am Queen also you really want raw
requests you know you're you're looking
you're looking for that needle in a
haystack
you're
to fight every single needle in that
haystack every single needle should be
findable every single
API request should be locatable you
should be able to tell if a report is
accurate or not
aggregation once you have yeah once you
have the time series aggregates like we
all know how they work right you have an
interval maybe a second or whatever
everything it happens that interval just
gets smooshed you just throw it away
you could never under the context you
never go back you can never ask the same
arbitrary open-ended questions that you
could with the raw data you need you
need more detail and you need more
context not less and and by this I mean
right time aggregation of course read
time aggregation is terrific you can get
the same benefits without the cost but
nobody seems to be doing that other than
us this is part of what I'm talking
about I want all of you who are going to
go home and build tools please build
more of these things like this is not a
sales pitch this is a cry for help black
swans are the norm you can't hunt your
needles if you can't find the outliers
I'm not just talking percentiles I'm
talking actual max and men here are
examples of really powerful awesome
things you can do if you're just
collecting and sampling like those raw
requests for example I think that the
only reason that DBAs exists is the good
the tooling is so shitty it's just a
complicated piece of software like
everybody knows how to do one thing look
for slow queries in the slow query log
but then they go out [ __ ] well this
query hasn't changed in two years uh you
know and and and the reason why is
because what they're looking at is you
know the reads because the read could
yield writes get yield
I'm never going to show up there and
what you're probably looking for is
what's holding the lock just please tell
me where is the lock time being held by
you know every platform that uses my
sequel to store their user data has this
problem where you know a bot the bot
gets starts running I can get hub you
know bot starts doing all these crazy
things or you know a iOS gap gets
submitted to the iPhone iTunes store
goes to the top you know all these
things happen and unpredictably and the
Sentra
she starts watching you know just like
to the ground and everybody's suffering
like at Paris like this was a story of
our lives and then we get into a [ __ ] in
a scuba and we just like oh 97.3% the
right luck times go into that user point
throttled like it's transformative Oh
feel so excited or or like you know yeah
I don't know you know what I'm talking
about
rich advanced dude they're so cool
they're so cool you can do so much stuff
with them databases are just I I firmly
believe that if you have this type of
truly you can hold your Android and iOS
developers accountable for their own
[ __ ] queries users don't care what
the system health is they just don't
that means I don't care either nice not
to care you need to test in production
this is like the PS so he's gonna snuck
in there
like think about the National the
electrical grid right you're not going
to bring up the staging copy of that
honestly most of the time that I
personally have spent on staging and the
time that I've seen other people spend
on staging has been completely wasted
completely wasted it drifts gets out of
sync the data isn't the same like you're
like look that long thin tail a problem
does that represent most of your actual
problems going forward and now we're
gonna turn up there and even if you did
it like i i'm the proud author of some
capture replay software that will
capture everything going into a system
for 24 hours and replay it with
concurrency and all this cool [ __ ] love
it it's limited even if you captured me
play yesterday's traffic you cannot
predict tomorrow's like you can't
predict what app is gonna get launched
you can't predict any of that stuff and
the place everyone is under investing
hugely is in tooling for production and
failing fast in rolling back in canaries
right stage rule-outs
ones where you know like i was tweeting
[ __ ] up about this couple weeks ago
because facebook finally released a blog
post and like yeah we can do play from
master now who now that may seem like a
big deal to you may not it should seem
like a big deal to you when you remember
how many interns they have the works for
fit yeah and the way to do it is first
they deploy to the internal
but for everyone right at 1% canary and
then promotes a 5% 10% whatever and then
they deployed to the you know the life
grade and everything um so good and like
we all have limited engineering time and
people are so scared of breaking
production but they're not accepting the
fact that we do like we do test in
production we can't not because it
doesn't matter how many and by the way
I'm not saying don't test before
production these are not mutually
exclusive do that please but then also
like invest that engineering time into
into feature flags you know into
shipping things safely and making it
your education so that every engineer
knows how to get to a good state making
it so the multiple versions could live
alongside each other data migrations so
this kind of leads into my last point
which is that I really believe that like
the future belongs to the generalist
software engineers you know they're in
the driver's seat I feel like the first
wave of DevOps was like okay I'll people
time to write code it's like yeah okay
we got it
got it we're already code down and now
it's like the second wave was just begun
which is all right software engineers
time to learn to mind your own [ __ ] you
know and no one is saying that like
these specializations are going away Ops
is always going to be needed it's just
that an increasing he's on the other
side of an API right and suffer
engineers no one is saying you have to
like do all your own backups like this
what we are saying is you can't craft
scalable well design services without
understanding how they work that's not
so controversial no is it
I feel like DBAs ops people you know
every every every role that is not a
general of software engineers
increasingly and they were force
amplifiers right we're amazing at
helping you run your own stuff or we
work on the other side of api's and
there's a lot of awesome like superhero
powerfulness and just being able
understanding how the lifecycle of your
code after you've hit [ __ ] it's 20 2017
like we wouldn't hire excessive min who
can't write a line of code we should not
be hiring or promoting software
engineers who will not accept
responsibility for their services now I
get why for so long it was so awful it's
just like I don't want to torture myself
like the ops people do like I don't
wanna torture myself either but I get
that this is somewhat self-inflicted
like as a as a as a group we are not
known for our work-life balance
own it I will it doesn't have to be
awful it really doesn't have to be awful
instrumentation is part of building
software and watching it run in
production is your [ __ ] job if you
don't watch it when it's normal you
won't know what abnormal looks like and
I and I think that like we're trying to
build something that makes it easy for
you just like poke around look and more
people need to accept this as insanity
it's insanity that's so often you hit
deploy and you never looked at it unless
it's wrong your code is not shipped
until it's in the wild and your code is
not tested until you've watched it
running with real data talking to real
services handling real users real
traffic patterns so great reviews last
two slides were these the way to think
about observability and glorious future
think about distributed systems the
research has been focusing on these
problems for decades we can learn things
from them even though I kind of forget
to academia exists it doesn't distribute
systems failures will help you
future-proof your systems and good news
what you win is like I said member I
said one of the best practices for
monitoring was you have all these alerts
and stuff I believe that with these big
complex far-flung district systems the
only tractable way to run them is with
like for paging alerts like that's it
just latency errors you know the big
three and then maybe saturation if you
trust your ability to debug any problem
in just a couple of clicks and if you
built resiliency into every level of it
you should almost never get woken up in
the middle the night and this may seem
like a pipe dream and jog level John
Lennon's immortal words or whatever but
it's not like I lived through this
I've lived through this repeatedly it
works it's beautiful
so I just had like summary of the old
way the new way the way things are
changing and that's it thank you
[Applause]